à tresques et sébastien ont le rire plus
facile cette semaine aux mondiaux qui
envoie la nuit le couple déclaré positif
à la coke et 19 le 17 mars va beaucoup
mieux
bien que la santé s'améliore ils sont
loin d'être rassurés jordi comme
d'amener ces gdg de dubaï après 48 ans
en pierre puis après votre confinement
de 14 jours vous devriez carakan à
l'épicerie ou bien est allé à pharmacie
sans problème à juger des appels de
médecins qui me disent non c'est 36
jours qu'il faut prendre assise à la
maison puis ensuite belgique du buteur
qui est dit dans le livre a testé mais
fait comme si c'était un premier test
êtes le peuple vous avez déjà détesté
s'effectuent les consignes de la santé
publique sont changeantes
au début on dit oui ça prenait 2,24
faire perdre à négative mais c'est en
train de changer
les recommandations changera je ne selon
les consignes du gouvernement
c'est un professionnel de la santé qui
juge si une personne infectée plus tard
était visuellement le deuxième test de
dépistage est exigé pour certaines
personnes comme le personnel soignant
on n'applique pas les mêmes mesures pour
tout le monde on veut être plus prudent
pour les patients qui sont hospitalisés
pour les travailleurs de la santé et
pour les patients qui seraient dans des
chsct pour monsieur madame tout le monde
quitte à la qui sont restés à la maison
qui ont une infection peu sévère
on sait avec quand même que les données
préliminaires qui proviennent des autres
pays que ces patients-là pramac au bout
de 10 à 14 jours ils ne sont plus
contagieux et en prenant qu'on perdrait
en fait une ressource précieuse de tests
en les re tester les autorités se
veulent rassurantes mais ce n'est pas
suffisant pour patrick sébastien il
aimerait en avoir le coeur net
je vais pas sortir dans oslo tâche est
quoi l assuré le maire moi comme
batterie dit on veut surtout pour
effecter personne donnée
c'est le but premier reste à la maison
le catch est apparemment vous êtes guéri
tu fais comme ok apparemment je n'aime
pas tellement par un moment donné c'est
vrai qu'être catman de souffle puis
quintin avec tattoo sa part rassuré son
bolide est ici marie michèle osant
radio-canada à montréal